[Musique]
je pense que être dj fin dans un pays
comme la tunisie
c'est un c'est comme une lutte contre
une société qui nous interdit de
pratiquer nos moby ou notre art
librement juste parfois parce que nous
sommes des femmes
[Musique]
être une femme djette en tunisie ça fait
peur car tu vas rentrer la nuit tard et
c'est plutôt un truc masculin donc
toutes les familles en pleurs raison
peur
ta part le rssi
dans les boîtes de nuit
les événements pendant la nuit surtout
[Musique]
là
nous combattons pour que le deejaying
soir a reconnu comme un métier en tant
que tel et à travers la dj akademy
fougueuse et la fabrique on met en place
des formations mais aussi de des
opportunités de réseautage de
collaboration entre les musiciennes les
dj les productrices les ingénieurs de
sang pour qu'elle développe aussi des
projets communs
[Rires]
[Musique]